i think there might be general agreement
that it is somewhat difficult to present
a clear account
of four years of work upon a
controversial topic
a new surgical approach to the treatment
of mental illness in 10 minutes
in an attempt to accomplish this task i
would like to read an abstract from a
paper scheduled for presentation of the
harvey cushing society
at its annual meeting in st louis
missouri on april the 19th 1966
i will then illustrate its content and
add as much to it as time allows
the abstract will read as follows
the beneficial effects of interruption
of cingulate fibers upon certain
psychiatric illnesses
have been well documented over the last
twenty years by cairns lewin poole and
lebeau among others
these surgeons have however preferred a
direct attack on the singulum
in 1961 fultz and white presented to
this society that is the harvey cushing
society
a series of 16 patients suffering from
intractable pain in whom lesions were
placed in the cingulum by stereotactic
electrode placement for the relief of
pain using a slight modification of
their technique we began in 1962 an
investigation of this procedure for the
treatment of mental illness primarily
manic depressive psychosis
to date 51 psychiatric patients have
been operated upon 75 times
10 have had cingulotomy performed for
the intractable pain of incurable cancer
there have been no operative or
post-operative complications no patients
have to date suffered undesirable
alterations personality or intelligence
thirty six of forty psychiatric patients
followed three months to four years
postoperatively
have shown varying degrees of
improvement
and in thirty this has been useful
improvement
seven of the ten cancer patients have
had satisfactory pain relief
that's the end of the abstract now if we
may have the illustrative material
we have the first slide please
this is the area under attack the limbic
system
more specifically the cingulum
this fiber bundle the cingulum bundle
seems to be the main link between the
frontal lobes and the limbic lobe the
latter is thought to be in animals at
least a prime regulator of behavior and
emotion
if i may be permitted to use the term
emotion in respect to animals
may we have the next slide please
a word about technique
bilateral burr holes are placed 9.5
centimeters posterior to the nasion
and 1.3 to 1.5 centimeters to either
side of the midline
specially designed in number 17
ventricular needles insulated except for
the distal centimeter are inserted into
the ventricles and air is injected
if the ventricular needles have pierced
the cingulum appropriately they are
withdrawn until the bare ends lie in the
cingulate region and then the radiation
is carried out may i add the next slide
please
initially the lesions replaced 2.5
centimeters posterior to the anterior
tips of the frontal horns and you can
see the
needles in the cingulum in this slide
this is according to the method of
faults in white experience and a
suggestion from paul yakovlev
a very famous
neuropathologist has induced us to
select a target four centimeters back of
the tips of the frontal horns in our
more recent operations
using a radio frequency lesion generator
a current of 8 watts is applied to the
electrodes for 60 seconds
two contiguous lesions are placed
vertically in each cingulum may i have
the next slide please
this is a whole brain section stained by
the lawyers method it has been taken at
about the locus of our lesions and is
presented for orientation purposes the
shaded areas show the area of the
cingulate destruction may i have the
next slide please
this is an example of the destruction
produced
this brain section comes from a man with
intractable pain who died from his lung
cancer note the relatively large size of
the lesions
we believe that adequate destruction is
vital to surgical success
ten cancer patients with severe pain
have been subjected to cingulotomy
adequate pain relief was obtained in
seven
for periods up to three months
our main purpose however has been to
investigate cingulotomy as a method of
treating the mentally ill
and the remainder of my remarks will be
concerned with 40 psychiatric patients
who have been followed three months to
four years after their last operation
let me
have the next slide please
these are the major symptoms of the 40
psychiatric patients 34
are thought to have had a severe mood
disturbance of the manic depressive type
and six the diagnosis is in doubt
all of the group have been treated with
talk and medicine
39 of the 40 had pre-operative
electroshock therapy
note also
that 35 of the 40 were totally disabled
that's the second line in that
slide
these patients represent a refractory
five percent of the total patient load
at the hospital which had been treating
them
now the next slide please
this chart shows the age at onset and at
operation
we have been dealing mostly with a
younger group of patients many of whom
might have been called schizophrenic by
other psychiatrists and all of whom
a difficult treatment problem our
youngest patient was 15
the oldest 80.
the average preoperative duration of
illness was about 10 years now i have
the next slide please
now these are our results the eight
patients called well
are currently symptom-free the markedly
improved group are functioning
effectively in society although
psychiatric supervision and some form of
treatment are still necessary
the improved patients are still disabled
but at the time of the presentation of
this paper they do not require
hospitalization
the slightly improved and unimproved
require no further categorical
delineation we might try to excuse this
lack of useful improvement on the
grounds of errors in psychiatric
diagnosis
improper lesion placement inadequate
lesion size and so forth but i will uh
resist this temptation
grab the next slide please
this is a comparison of the results of
surgery for mental illness is recorded
by different observers scrutinizing
different operations
the degree of improvement
is about the same in all three groups
and is surprisingly similar to that
reported by agus moniz 30 years ago
in his first article published in 1936
moniz stated that 14 of 20 psychiatric
patients subjected to frontal lobotomy
were better post operatively and that
five of the six failures occurred in
patients suffering from schizophrenia
in one respect however and i refer you
to the last column
in one respect however the cingulotomies
and cingulectomies are different from
the leukotomy series the operation seems
to be much safer
now a word about
multiple operations
10 of the 40 psychiatric patients have
had more than one operation and one
patient has had seven
his iq remains about 130.
in this latter respect i want to make it
clear that i do not believe that
cingulotomy can turn a [ __ ] into a
genius but it is true that if nine
patients who had cortical function tests
before and after operation
none was worse post-operatively and six
had slightly higher scores
may i have the next slide please
this short bibliography has two virtues
the articles listed are excellent in
themselves and they also contain copious
additional references for the serious
student of the subject of operative
attempts to influence the course of
mental illness
in conclusion then
we have carried out 85 bilateral
singulotomies on 61 patients
10 of these operations have been for
pain and we have been able to confirm
the findings of faults in white
that cingulotomy is a value in
controlling otherwise intractable pain
75 of these operations have been done
for mental illness primarily those
conditions characterized by profound and
chronic
of affect
30 of 40 patients followed three months
to four years after operation have shown
useful improvement
these good results could be due to
chance to the so-called non-specific
effects of surgery or to other factors
than surgical intervention
naturally we prefer to think that there
is a specific operative effect but we
have no concrete proof of this
the operation does seem to be safe
however and this despite the fact that
our lesions have been large
we believe that it is necessary to
destroy the most medial cingulate fibers
bilaterally and have re-operated
patients to be certain of this
destruction as well as to enlarge the
lesion
finally and most importantly i as a
neurosurgeon do not believe that this
operation is a panacea for mental
illness not even for effective disorders
such as manic depressive disease or
psychosis
cingulotomy should be considered an
incident in the total treatment of the
severely disabled patient and any
neurosurgeon who performs it will be
disappointed in his results unless he is
able to work with psychiatrists who will
treat these patients intensively before
and after surgery with all of the
chemical and physical agents available
for the biological approach to the
therapy of mental illness
you